Joe is peng!
I think Joe's good-looking.
-Venom! Venom!
-Wrong show, guys!
Tom. Tom Hardy,
if you're watching this,
come get me.
I'm in the ghetto.
Come get me.
Hi, friends and welcome back
to my brand new Netflix show
where me and my friends
get together
and debate about
our favourite Netflix shows.
And I get to decide
who wins the argument.
And that's a what?
-Period.
-Group A consists of...
-Amanda Char.
And Mimi Missfit.
And they'll
be going against...
-Rheanne Murray.
-And Rachel Bada.
Do you guys want to know
what we're debating today?
Let's go, let's go.
Stop shouting out
I'm just gonna reach
for my briefcase.
Age is really
catching up to me, isn't it?
All right, so...
Guys, the show we're going
to be discussing today
is actually a personal fav!
YOU!
I love a YOU.
-I love a YOU.
-Oh, I love you guys, too!
-No.
-Oh.
I'm going to need you guys
to solemnly swear
on my Netflix bible,
Swear that you guys will put
your best arguments forward.
-Can I get a amen?
-Amen.
Thank you, Jesus.
I like this briefcase.
It's a designer.
Custom-made for me.
The N is for Nella,
not Netflix.
N is for Nella, not Netflix.
When it comes to women,
it is said that we are
better at certain things
in comparison to men.
#facts
What I want to know is
who's most dangerous,
Joe or Love?
Group A,
be telling us why you think
Joe's a big,
big murderer here.
First of all,
I feel like he's actions
actually come from love.
As in like,
as in not the person,
as in love.
-There's a thin line...
-Don't wanna be loved again.
...which means he's scary.
I think he's just scary.
And Joe
is an original madness.
He's the OG,
Love just copied him.
I'm telling you, this one's
been imbredded in him
'cause everything he does
in the social media
to the tracing and tracking,
Joe is the original mad one!
All right, so group B,
please tell me
why you guys think
that Love is more dangerous
than my joe-joe bear.
She manipulated
the whole situation.
She escaped from prison
to go back to prison
to make Joe think
that he had captured her
when
she'd captured the mind.
It's all in the mind.
-Keep doing your eyes...
-Know what I mean?
In all honesty, as a judge,
I am breaking the law.
I am being a bit biased.
Oh, no.
So, you guys that think
that Love is more dangerous,
-to me, he's a little...
-Delusional?
Who said that?
-Amanda!
-Arms up.
Stop saying stuff.
Women are better than men
at a lot of things.
-We're better--
-We are stronger than men
when it comes
to giving birth,
pain tolerance,
periods, mentally...
And we're more
emotionally inclined.
But,
when it comes to fighting...
We're not talking
about the fighting.
-Mind's more dangerous.
-Let me tell you.
A man will cheat on a woman
and get caught,
a woman cheats on a man
and not get caught,
that's dangerous!
Right? That is...
-Love is the one--
-But he killed them.
-Yes, but Love is the one...
-Puppeteer.
Yes! She's the puppeteer.
He's the puppet.
That doesn't mean that Joe
is not more dangerous.
Like, Joe's the one that's
actually doing the work.
-She's the master...
-it doesn't matter!
Love thinks she's bad,
but there's always
somebody badder.
-Badder!
-And Joe is...
But Love,
if Joe goes to prison,
I will now manipulate
somebody else.
Joe's gonna kill
and get caught.
Okay, just look at all
the dictators in the world.
They are all moist.
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
They hire armies
and soldiers
of dangerous people,
to do their dirty work,
but when they now
turn against you...
But they are untouchable
at some point.
Love that works in bookshop,
wait, when does she--
-how is she untouchable?
-What's that guy's name?
Einstein, Instine?
He said
that he died in prison
and everybody else
has taken the fall for him
-with their coerce...
-Einstein?
-He was a mathematician.
-I know, I'm like Einstein?
Oh!
He's in one cave somewhere
chilling.
He was another one
in the forefront.
Obviously,
he was doing his jeje,
but he was getting
his people to do it!
The question is
who is more dangerous?
I say Joe. Why?
Because
Joe is still dangerous
-with or without Love.
-Period!
If Love wasn't there,
like...
He met Love in season 2.
In season 1, he was mad.
But you don't know
what Love was doing before.
Manipulating another man.
You don't know that!
Don't be writing
your own script!
Fun house.
Guys, do you feel like Joe
would still be dangerous
if he wasn't
so emotionally charged?
He'd be more dangerous.
I just feel like
he would be more...
-But he's not here, man.
-...it'll just be
like he didn't use
his initiative like that.
Like, you see how he will be
marinating his evil work.
He'll still be dangerous,
but more like...
-And quick to be dangerous.
-Yeah.
And Joe
is a good-looking man.
-And fan-boy...
-Barely.
He is a good-looking guy.
-Oh, my days!
-I plead the fifth.
I don't agree, no.
He's not a bad looking man
but like...
Okay, he seems
very normal looking.
Joe is penk!
-I think Joe's good-looking.
-When there's Cpt America
walking around for free.
That one that goes
in the water with the hair.
-Who's that one?
-Aquaman.
Aquaman!
Venom! Venom!
-Wrong show, guys!
Tom. Tom Hardy,
if you're watching this,
come get me.
I'm in the ghetto.
Do you know why
I agree with them
Joe's definitely
more dangerous?
Then let them,
just say they won.
A man that thinks
he's unseen
because
he's wearing a hat...
it's not okay.
Man will stand outside
of your window in a hat
and think he's blending
into the lamppost.
Joe will eventually get
caught 'cause he's careless,
like he wears a hat.
I agree with that.
-Okay, okay. What?
-Don't agree with them.
Who's side are you on?
-Love is like a home girl.
-But who's side are you on?
I'm still in our side.
This is one
of my favourite shows,
Loving every second of this.
Group A,
I really liked your argument
because you guys
are very factual.
He has a higher body count.
The real meaning
of body count.
Don't be stupid.
Listen. B, I really liked
your argument
because you have to be able
to master the master.
Because we thought Joe was
the master in season 1
and then in season 2...
left.
Can I get
a little drum roll, please,
so we can come to a verdict?
So...
the winner
of this round is...
Group A.
Period!
Joe is... he's a hitman.
He's 007,
like, he's James Bond.
With Love,
she's a mastermind.
And she's manipulative.
But when it comes
to carrying out action,
she won't be able to
grat-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta
the whole room, know I mean?
Let's move on
to the next case.
Do you think
lots of people do something
for the thrill
of getting caught?
I can only relate
when I'm playing
Knock-Down Ginger.
In this day and age?
Mind your business.
Do you think that Joe
will ever get caught
when it comes
to getting away with crime
or is Joe more lucky
than smart?
Well, my point
is very simple.
He's not gonna get caught
because then there's not
gonna be no more YOU.
Producer!
-Episode ended...
-Luck off.
On top of that,
he's killed so many people,
like, plus he's killed...
He's killed too many people.
-There was Kiesha...
-Rupert.
Too many people
and still hasn't got caught,
he's doing something right.
We feel like
Joe's running on luck
because we've seen him
do stuff off impulse.
When you do stuff
off impulse and emotion,
it's not always
the greatest thing.
We know that
we're doing it irrationally,
not as clean
and calculated as we want.
One day
the luck's gonna run out.
One day,
when that day comes,
-go to jail!
-Jail!
-Jump, baby.
-You gotta jump.
The man
has killed a lot of people.
They're serial killers.
Who do you think
is feeding him that luck?
-My God?
-Not our God, the devil.
Sometimes he works overtime.
...luck now.
But was you guys
not the same ones,
in the previous case,
saying that Love
has made him smarter?
This impulse
you guys are saying,
he's impulsive,
gonna get caught.
But Love is now--
But he's been impulsive
without Love's smartness.
-Do you get it?
-But now she's here...
Order in my court!
Have a question for you.
What was your point?
So, my point is
they're saying that.
He's impulsive 'cause he has
no like brain, just luck.
But Love
is making him smart.
-She controls everything.
-So, do you guys think--
You guys think he's
getting away with murder
-because he's smart, right?
-Yeah.
Do you think that standing
outside someone's window...
-With a cap on?
-No, no.
The same window that has
no curtains or blinds,
-with a hat.
-With a hat.
Face exposed, no bali on,
not even a mask,
it's pandemic.
Yeah. Right.
-You think that's...
-That's smart?
Yeah, that is smart.
Murders,
normally hide their faces.
You remember, to the public,
he's a good YOU.
-Yeah! He's a good YOU.
-So, of course, he's still--
has to be that person
in front of everyone else.
So, when Love
is controlling him, yeah?
That's when
he's doing stuff,
but you know impulse?
Impulse is when you do it
in that moment.
So, obviously, Love
has not premeditated that
-for him to do...
-So what's your point?
-...in the moment...
-Now she does.
Yes, but in the moment,
Love is not with him
all the time.
She is.
No, she's not.
Who told you that?
What's that point?
I wanna hear...
We was talking to Mimi.
Excuse me, Mimi.
-Team B.
-Team A.
This is team A.
-A, B, C, that's the end.
Anyway, guys, we feel like
Joe will get caught
'cause he's letting
his emotions getting--
Right, time!
I feel like it takes
a certain level of expertise
to be a murderer.
Me, if I was to kill
someone today
I'd be mourning them.
I'd be crying for them.
I'd be like, oh, my God,
what have I done?
On the other hand,
it's luck he's still alive.
Because you're standing
outside of someone's house
every single night
with a hat.
You think I'm not seeing her
calling the police
and say someone's stalking
my neighbour.
-It's the same hat.
-Know what I mean?
You rented
a storage system from me
and I'm not gonna see you
build a cage inside of that
for three months.
Follow me a drum roll.
So, I do feel like...
group A.
You know, I feel like
she's been biased
through this whole thing.
Guys, can I explain?
I feel like
I could rob a bank at 12
-and be arrested at 12:30.
-Do you know what I mean?
I feel like he's too good
at what he does
and that's why
he doesn't get caught.
He got taught that though.
Man was in cages from six.
I would like to announce
that the winner is...
-Group A.
-I mean, we do that, so...
-Um... to end...
-It's rigged, but it's fine.
No, but have we reiterate
Amanda's point as well,
there'll be no more YOU
and we need more YOU.
-Oh, yes. Yes.
-We actually need more YOU.
Can you renew it
for six seasons please?
-Don’t be selfish.
-Thanks.
But anyways, guys,
that is it from us
from this episode
of Judge Nella.
If you guys wanna see
more of me and my friends,
make sure
you guys subscribe,
turn on
your post notifications
and make sure
you guys like and comment.
And that's all. Period.
-Period.
She was a hostage.
And she just had
flimsy yut, bruv.
If you stay in court, you
can't say flimpsy yut.
Sorry.